just up these stairs to the concourse
area in Los Angeles Convention Center
where today as a luncheon speakers we're
going to have be hearing from Bill
O'Reilly who you just met here also Al
Franken and molly ivins all three of
them are going to be speaking and the
moderator for this event is former
Congresswoman patricia schroeder she's
just come to the podium I'm Pat
Schroeder from the Association of
American publishers and I can't tell you
how excited I am about this afternoon
program I don't think there's any chance
your lunch is going to get cold I think
we're going to have some nice fire up
here and it's going to be a lot of fun
first of all I have to apologize because
Tucker Carlson had a family emergency
and he will not be up here therefore I
am smiling because this is patch rotors
view of fair and balanced oh sorry um I
also want to say that we have a very
distinguished person in the audience
today one of my dear beloved former
colleagues who is out carrying the torch
24-7 and all of us have to make sure
that this works and that is congressman
Bernie Sanders from Vermont stand up for
me
you
and I see so many of you out there that
are friends and publishers and
booksellers and I think this is a
wonderful event where we all get
together but let me get out of the way
because we got some really marvelous
folks today first of all I'm supposed to
stand up here and be objective about
Molly Ivins and there is no way in the
world I can do that this is one of the
world's great treasures and i just am
soaked in shape yeah there's no other
word for she makes the sisterhood proud
you know she's got a column over 300
newspapers where she tries to set
everything straight for some reason she
is able to remain cheerful in this
political environment this wonderful
native of Houston went to smith college
she got her master's from Columbia
University School of Journalism and now
here is a little secret that I don't
know if I should say or not in the
climate were in she went to the
Institute of Political Science in Paris
yes where she said he's free to my
favorite songs free anyway she then went
to work for the Houston Chronicle and
had this first great job where she
worked her way up to being sewer editor
and obviously that naturally got a ride
into politics she found her course and
she has been there ever since we all
know though many many many of the
wonderful newspapers she's been with the
Minneapolis Tribune the New York Times
the Dallas Times Herald the fort worth
star-telegram Texas observer we could go
on and on some of the most distinguished
journalist stick instruments we have in
this country she's gone on to write
books that we've all been very proud of
she's won all sorts of awards and I
could give you all of those but I really
think what we're here today is about
this new book that's coming out and
believe me I have made a pledge to make
sure I live through fall because this
book is going to make my fall very much
worthwhile molly is here today because
as with random house they are coming out
with a great new book in the fall called
bushwhacked living with george w bush in
America I don't think anybody has had
more experience than a Texan who has
covered him from day one and I am just
going to get out of the way and turn
this over to my heroine Molly Ivins
Molly
thank y'all I thank y'all I know many of
you were there at the awards last night
and heard me speak and I apologize if
there's any overlap I want to tell you
another great reason to prefer
independent booksellers right after
shrub came out I was in Massachusetts
and the husband of a friend of mine came
up to me and said Molly I knew that I
would be seeing you this weekend so a
week ago I went to buy your book at the
Barnes & Noble in boston and i look
where i thought it would be a new
nonfiction and then I tried the politics
section and it wasn't there so I went to
the information counter and said y'all
have shrugged by molly ivins on the lady
said oh yes after she looked it up and
very proudly led me to the gardening
section all right um the publisher wants
me to talk about the new book and I'm
happy to do that we were tempted to
start the new book by saying in the
introduction if y'all have read the
first one I wouldn't I had to write this
one and i must say i think the
predictive value of shrub at this point
which as you know was based entirely on
Bush's record not on any personal
characteristics was very strong in its
predictive value the one area of course
where we we were not able to be helpful
was the foreign direction of foreign
policy shrub wound up being quoted on
the floor of Congress during the run-up
to the political debate because the only
stabbed it or we could make it in that
field was observed uh you know I've
known both since high school I didn't
know him well let me point out but I
have known in the awful long time and he
does have a much of competitive streak
that it tends to be touched off by very
strong sort of testosterone poison males
if I may put it that way and we just
made no to this
but instead in person somebody should
probably be worrying about this in terms
of you know a future his future
encounters with some Saddam Hussein a
moment oppressions of course which we
can now brag about okay the new book as
I mentioned last night is based on an on
premise that Jim Hightower now came up
with which is that the media in this
country pay far too much attention to
the Dow Jones average and what we really
need is the Doug Jones average doug
jones average American and household
Doug doing is he up is he down how's it
going for Doug and I think you know we
should have a daily report on that so
what Lou and I did Lou turbos my writing
partner in every chapter we start with
some change in policy that's been made
by the Bush administration and then we
trace it out and see how it affects real
people in their everyday lives and this
is an idea so old that it's new again
people look at it's in astonishment it
used to be what political reporting was
about how the government affects your
life but somehow we've gotten away from
that and there's this terrible
disconnect between Washington and the
rest of the country and many of our
fellow citizens just don't see how
government is shaping their lives
they're indifferent to it they think it
doesn't have anything to do with them
they're under the impression that it's
all them it's those people it's those
people in Washington it's those people
in Austin that they don't have anything
to do with it and as you know it's one
of my theories of life is that not only
is government us we own it you made all
of us and we run it where the board of
directors those people work for us and
so we went around the country having
various adventures on and meeting
fabulous people I told last night the
story of the women in the Delta pride
catfish factory in belzoni Mississippi
these women do 12 catfish a minute and
their hands look like they've got
rheumatoid arthritis they've got these
big things called gangly attic cysts on
top from repetitive stress and they had
never heard of the people in Washington
who killed off ergonomic regulations
they had no idea who Eugene Scalia was
or that he'd been a lobbyist for the
trade association opposed to economic
regulations before bush appointed him to
be the top lawyers the Labor Department
and when they when we told them about it
of course their reaction was classically
we were prepared to you know play the
Durga to say all these poor pitiful
victims of bad policy and all that but
the thing about Americans is that they
are sassy and funny and irreverent and
you cannot keep them down and we told
these ladies about what had happened on
the ergonomics regulation and they would
say things like he said that be junk
science will you tell him I want his
hands next to me on the cutting up line
I was showing him drunk times I mean
they were fabulous and everywhere we
went we met the most extraordinary and
feisty Americans there's a rancher out
in western Wyoming he's a sort of
straight out of a Marlboro poster he
looks like a more of our cowboy here and
she's like a Margaret a boy he's the
real thing and one day he hits it his
ranch is watered by a stream which of
course water being scarce in that part
of the country he has carefully worked
over the years to put in berms to take
advantage of every single drop that
comes through and suddenly his water
turned poisonous and started killing his
grass so of course he had to cut back on
his herd and he's been severely damaged
and he may not he wants to pass that
ranch on to his son but he may not be
able to do so so he goes the government
for help with this problem and the guy
in question is name JS steven griles
he's the number two man at interior the
problem is that upstream from this ranch
coalbed methane operators putting in
wells to get out methane gas and what
happens in to the course of doing that
is they put in water the water picks up
salinity
poisons the rivers than the creeks J
steven griles to whom our man tried to
go with his complaint was formerly the
lobbyist for the coal bed methane
operators association and not exactly
sympathetic to the ranchers point of
view this is the kind of thing that we
found again and again this Rancher was a
member of the National Rifle Association
here former chairman of the county
republican party he had justice staunch
a Republican as you could wish and he
has joined an environmental group out
there because he cannot get any relief
or any help from his own government he's
tried suing him and basically as he says
he's paying for the his lawyer to sue
the government and he's paying for the
government's lawyer through his taxes
and he doesn't you can't quite figure
out here he got himself into this mess
because he didn't do anything anybody
the further part on the grounds chapter
is that crawls tried to kill off an EPA
report on the proposed overall methane
operators plan which said that the thing
was el stinko and would kill both the
main rivers that provide all the water
in northwestern Wyoming growls try to
have that one buried everywhere we went
we found people who were really heroes
we were looking into the result of the
decision on super fund the Bush
administration will not push to
reinstate the tax on chemical companies
that pays for super fun toxic side
cleanups and I've always said Bush's
chemical dependency problem has nothing
to do with cocaine it has to do with Dow
in Monsanto they were the forces that
put him in office down in Texas the
trouble with there's now no money left
in the super
they cut off the tax that paid for
cleaning up orphan sites but it's more
than that it's not just that the orphan
sites those abandoned with no at what
they call legally responsible parties
can't get cleaned up the way the
government has gotten chemical companies
and other polluters to clean up toxic
waste sites is by saying either you do
it or we'll do it and charge you three
times as much as it costs us well now
there's no money in the Superfund site
they can't go ahead and clean up these
sites where there are responsible
parties and then find them for the costs
and as a result all the cleanup has
stopped we met a fellow who got
interested in this problem in Edison New
Jersey one day he's a caterer pastry
chef and one of his friends said to him
you want to see some green rabbits and
he went out and by god they were green
bunny rabbits hopping around and one of
the all-time worst fly-by-night sleazy
chemical operators of all time had left
huge pits containing everything from
agent orange to something called Dinah
seven you never heard such a nightmare
of toxic chemicals in your life and the
status of actually turns buttons green
and so this guy got really interested in
the question he was thinking well if it
turns rabbits green what if the hell is
it doing to the kids around here and
they finally got it declared a toxic
waste site and they got it on the
Superfund list but of course that's now
that great victory which took them
almost 10 years of citizen activant
action I mean that in the best tradition
talking to sate bureaucrats getting
government off they say ass getting them
up there to investigate what all this
stuff was it took ten years and then of
course whim oh they were on the list but
the fund ran out of money again and
again we're finding this pattern it's
particularly
kien in the environmental area but it
goes across the board I want to take too
much time but in the few chapters where
we address not individual lives and what
is being done to them but the larger
context of what's happened old Doug
Jones the numbers are not looking good
at any level the number of people losing
pensions losing health care keeps going
up the so-called pension reform program
put up by the administration is going to
adversely affect millions of older
workers the list goes on and on and the
bottom line is that old Doug Jones is
getting screwed and I've always thought
that the only questions in government or
who's getting screwed and who's doing
the screwing Benito Mussolini once said
that fascism should more properly be
called corporatism because it is the
merger of corporate and government power
now I don't know if what we're looking
at is fascism but i'm telling you we
spent a year and a half research in this
book and old of jones is not doing well
thank you
Thank You Molly and our next stuff
authored this morning or this afternoon
is Bill O'Reilly who i'm sure all of
them are say they're all here for you
it's very clear he is the host of
winning the most-watched talk news shows
on cable television and he's had a
tremendous long long standing career in
television before he is now currently on
fox news channel the o'reilly factor but
he was at ABC for many years where he
was an Inside Edition he's won two Emmy
Awards and we in the book selling and in
book publishing are very happy because
he's had two top of the list books
recently they're absolutely wonderful
number one on the New York Times The
O'Reilly Factor was one and no spin zone
was number two and guess what come
September he's ready to come out with a
new one and as new books going to be
called who's looking out for you it's
published by Broadway books his
publisher and it's going to be looking
at all the problems post-911 and what is
really going to be happening or what has
been happening so he may have a little
bit different perspective on not doug
jones and i'm going to be very
interested to hear which o to say bill
bill microphones yours go
thank you Miss Schroeder good afternoon
everyone who's looking out for you is a
very personal book it's not a political
book I don't write political books my
first two were the first one was the
o'reilly factor basically was a primer
on how i arrived at my philosophy of
life and then the no spin zone was the
combat that I went through on the factor
television program with the major news
makers in America and this book who's
looking out for you is a personal book
about you now I don't know you but I
know about you and I take on all of the
powers in the country in a
non-ideological way in the sense that i
feel that ideology is harmful to you I
don't feel that people pushing political
agendas and philosophies does you any
good at all I think that you should
arrive at your own conclusions based
upon facts and analysis I'm not like
Rush Limbaugh who wants to convert you
to his way of thinking and if you don't
feel the way he that he does then he'll
denigrate you or called you know put you
in a category I don't do that I'm
basically go out there and I'm a problem
solver and I say here's the problem
here's a situation here's how I would
deal with it here's how they are dealing
with it are they looking out for you or
not therefore we can get a lot of
different areas I get into the horrible
situation that we have in a criminal
justice system where the rich wind and
truth doesn't matter at all because the
lawyers aren't required to tell the
truth in the David Westerfield Daniel
van damme case right down I five in San
Diego's invested those lawyers lied they
flat-out lied in the courtroom and
nobody'll anything about it costing the
state of California millions of dollars
and the guy got convicted ultimately but
when we interviewed the jurors after the
trial they bought this crazy scenario
that the van damme friends might have
done it they were considering that very
seriously when these lawyers knew
that their client killed a
seven-year-old girl because they offered
a deal before the trial started to lead
the police to the body all right we
filed a formal complaint with the
California Bar Association which of
course will not do anything because it's
a big club house so those are the kinds
of things that I get into now I do take
on the the demagogues in the United
States but I don't call anybody a liar
I'm not doing that I'm not calling
anybody big fat I'm not doing that
alright not too big on that kind of
stuff you know trying to elevate the
discourse here
now let me give you an example of
ideology gone mad the weapons of mass
destruction which is I think the most
important story right now and play for
everybody in the United States on the
right you have the lockstep people going
well Saddam Hussein was his own weapon
of mass destruction that's the right
spin okay and you know these spin
talking points come out every morning
both on the right and the left I don't
get them I'm sure al does but I don't
and then they it becomes a mantra all
right so they'll call up the talk shows
and I go doesn't matter we haven't found
any anthrax Saddam Hussein was his own
weapon of mass destruction well that's a
bunch of garbage it's nonsense okay if
we don't have intelligence agencies here
who can ascertain who has what and we're
in trouble those people gave false
intelligence to the Pentagon and the
president then those people got to be
fired flat out they're gone no excuses
okay now we got Colin Powell screaming
today he saw the intelligence with his
own eyes all right fine then you're
going to have to explain a little bit
further but unlike some other ideologues
i am not going to condemn anybody i'm
not going to say there was a conspiracy
i'm not going to do those connected dots
because i don't think that's legitimate
all right I'm going to demand an
explanation but I'm willing to hear the
explanation and here's what else
separates me from ideologues both on the
right and the left I want the United
States to find the weapons of mass
destruction I want them to find it
because that's what's best for our
country not what's best for Bush what's
best for the United States because if
they don't find them we lose credibility
throughout the world and the people who
hate us have more argument to hate us
all right so I want them to find those
weapons and I make that quite clear not
to push any ideology I couldn't care
less who the president next president it
doesn't matter to me all right and I
back that up all day long you know I
can't get people to come on a factor
from the Bush administration yeah come
on way too tough event you call Jeb Bush
find out what he thinks about me so
people who try to you know on both the
right and the left and the left weapons
of mass destruction is complete hysteria
it isn't there they made it up well how
do they know what isn't there maybe
they'll find it you know how do they
know Robert Scheer knows he doesn't know
anything now when you get blinded by
your ideology as many of Americans are
you can't think straight because what
you're trying to do is you're trying to
find facts to fit your hypothesis okay
that doesn't help you out you've got to
look at it tough and hard what the truth
is how you arrived at the conclusions
now I'm an analyst all right and when I
say something I back it up now if I'm
going to be accused of being a liar now
you better have something there because
in six and a half years on a Riley
factor on one year on the radio two
hours a day five days a week i have not
had to retract one story not one course
we've made mistakes factual mistakes and
we correct them as every newspaper does
every day you'll see the correction
column but we have not had to retract
one story because we are very methodical
in the way we go about our presentation
now who's looking out for you also I
think whether you like me or not you'll
love this chapter I tell you all the
mistakes that I made in very vivid
detail so you don't make them all right
because I live in a very competitive
brutal world and I I gave my detractors
more than enough rope to hurt me and it
did hurt and I tell you here's what I
did but the basic theme of the book is
chaos breeds more chaos and the clear
thinking people and discipline people
will have a happy life and if you're not
disciplined you won't and the government
can't make you have a happy life the
fallacy on the left is that they believe
all of these money and these programs
and everything are going to lift people
up well they're not what lifts people up
is discipline is sobriety is principles
is hard work has nothing to do with the
government now the government can
provide a safety net and should but if
you think that you're going to solve
social problems
by pumping gazillions of dollars in
their crazy or not it's personal
behavior that matters in this country
that is what makes people successful
personal behavior not governmental
behavior so we get into that in the book
and in no uncertain terms and then I run
down to politicians all of them and I
say is this guy looking out for you and
you know what one man can look out for
you on one end and not look out for you
on the other it isn't black or white it
is in all or nothing John F Kennedy the
best example of that and Bill Clinton is
an example of that too he did some very
good things in office things that I
supported and applauding but he did some
very bad things too and I'm sure we'll
find out the same about Bush when the
truth comes to the fore about his
policies so who's looking out for you is
basically a book for you not for me all
right and i use my 30 years of
journalists experience to lay it out as
best I can and I'm real tough on myself
and I'm real tough on some other people
like fuel are not looking out for you we
need names of course we have a lot of
fun we name names we don't call names
thank you for your kind attention
thank you Bill and our last presenter
this afternoon is Al Franken and
absolutely no idea what I can say about
Al Franken that he hasn't said about
himself how I'm standing up here
thinking uh uh uh what do I is that I
think we all first ran across him when
he started with Saturday Night Live as a
writer and of course he's gone on and
written some absolutely wonderful things
including but most people don't I was
one of the coke writers of winter man
loves a woman he's been able to do a
whole range of things but we know him
for his wonderful comedy he's won five
Emmys which is amazing and really I
think something to be applauded
discarded is a political commentator
with CNN and of course my very favorite
was the 1996 commentating that he did
with Arianna Huffington his strange
bedfellows if any of you remember that
it really brought television to a new
level really brought pillow talk a whole
new thing um Alice had some amazing
books and big bestsellers one was and I
did like this one Rush Limbaugh is a big
fat idiot I you know like sorry and he's
gone on to do several other books that
we all know and love that this fall
there is a new one coming out by Dutton
his publisher is Dutton and he is coming
forward with a book called lies and the
lying liars who tell him a fair and
balanced view of the right ladies and
gentlemen Al Franken
thank you hey here's uh here's the the
preliminary cover of Lies and the lying
liars who tell them a fair and balanced
look at the right and built we talked
about this before the picture you if we
can get one from the factor would be
great because he wasn't it wasn't happy
with this one and you know this is a
public domain picture and just any
picture of you with your mouth open
would be good we're asked what inspires
about to write this book actually god I
asked me to write this book because he
was so pissed off at at Busch who
claimed his friends claimed that he had
been chosen by God and God said actually
he hadn't chosen by Clarence Thomas
it was interesting process with this
book I was asked to be a fellow at the
Kennedy School we were graduate and they
at the shortening Center and they asked
me to be a fellow there I said what do I
have to do and they said nothing but
write something and I said well you
don't want me to teach anything I said
well you can have a study group and and
teach something there so I I had a study
group of 14 great kids from accounting
school and undergraduates and I taught
them to research my book basically the
book starts as a response to Bernie
Goldberg and Coulter about this supposed
the Smith of the liberal bias in the
media and kind of the premises of the
whole book the start of the book is that
asking whether there's a liberal or
conservative bias in the mainstream
media is like asking if the problem with
al Qaeda is that they use too much oil
in their hummus the problem with Al
Qaeda's they want to kill us the bias
ease of the mainstream media are far
there are many many biases and
sensationalism horse raise get it first
do it cheap there's just so many more
important biases and the idea that
there's a liberal bias in the media that
is it's just ridiculous all you have to
do is like look at the coverage of Klum
I mean especially during the monitor
thing was 24 7 Monica and there were
some news organizations that did not
succumb to that temptation I'd like to
cite them wherever I go sailing magazine
American grocer monthly jugs and big but
which is ironic because I thought big
but you know I had a story and then if
you look at the two thousand campaign
that the idea that there was a bias on
behalf of gore is ridiculous remember in
the one of the debates a Gore said that
he had gone to Texas to go to a disaster
with James Lee wit the head of FEMA
turned out he hadn't gone to that
disaster with James Lee wit he went with
a deputy of James Lee wit he went to 17
other disasters with James Lee wit not
that one press jumps all over he's a
liar it was if James Lee wit was the
most popular man in America and gore was
lying just to get some of that James Lee
wit magic you know to rub off on another
one of the two thousand debates Bush
says this and this is a quote by far the
vast majority of my tax cut goes to
those at the bottom by far
a vast majority of my tax that goes to
those at the bottom nothing from the
press not a thing and is it because they
have a conservative bias I don't think
so i think their attitude was he doesn't
know he doesn't know leave him alone he
doesn't know and so now we have this new
tax cut and every tax cut of course is
going to the people at the top and bill
is supported all of those tax cuts and
they'll do great efforts on the economy
let me talk a little one thing about the
economy this is i love statistics
because they never lie numbers never lie
in the six years plus of the two bushes
have been president there have been
actually negative net jobs not one new
net job has been created extrapolating
on that if the bushes had head of this
country from the very beginning our
country's inception to the present time
not one American would have ever worked
not one so you know they do this
sometimes they they still say it that it
oh the bottom gets the biggest tax cut
look at someone making twenty six
thousand dollars gets their taxes a
hundred percent tax cut all their income
taxes are cut by this a hundred percent
tax cut well of their income tax and
maybe they're paying two hundred dollars
in income tax and Oh dick cheney he's
only getting an eight percent cut jay it
looked a hundred percent cut for the
waitress and only an eight percent cut
for dick cheney which isn't like a
million dollars or half a million dollar
whatever hundred thousand thank you mom
sometimes the overstate
but but this person making 26,000 made
it single mother then a loser Medicaid
then a loser Medicaid for kids gonna pay
is going to pay Morton in state taxes
because their states are in terrible
shape the kids are going to have there's
going to be less money going into
schools Kentucky's releasing prisoners I
mean this is this is crazy what we're
doing and this huge huge deficit
remember Bush said when we first went in
the deficit with him he said well I said
during the campaign that you know we
don't the only way we go into deficit is
we had a recession a national emergency
or war well I guess I hit the trifecta
right remember said that except you know
what he didn't say that during the
campaign Washington Post we'll look back
he'd never said it one person did say it
was Al Gore Bush not great with language
evildoers for example member when he's
first started using evildoers and every
the rest of administration felt they had
to use evildoers to it was really fun to
watch like Dick Cheney have to slip in
evildoers it was like this is not a war
against Islam this is an effort to
eradicate the
evildoers
so there's no the mainstream media does
not have a bias left or right there is
however a right-wing media and we know
who they are The Wall Street Journal
editorial page talk radio which talk so
eloquently about Bill a fox fair and
balanced talk about Orwellian I mean
come on and I and I think they go back
into the create an echo effect in the
media and as a result I think the whole
media has moved to the right now I
answer a couple of books then that's
part of the right-wing media too and I
know that you publishers are going to
start publishing more right-wing books
for you know the bulk sales so that
Richard melon Scaife can you know use
Mona Sharon's books for mulch but Ann
Coulter's book I had take on I writer
chapter and Ann Coulter and she's brags
about having 752 footnotes and we
actually she has no footnotes she has
endnotes there's a difference because
you don't check me and notes especially
I think her readers or she at least
depends on that for example let me quote
from her book after Supreme Court
Justice Clarence Thomas wrote an opinion
contrary to the clearly expressed
position of the New York Times editorial
page The Times responded with an
editorial on Thomas titled the youngest
cruelest justice that was actually the
headline on a lead editorial in the
newspaper of record Thomas is not
engaged on the substance of his judicial
philosophy is called a colored lawn
jockey for conservative white interests
race traitor black snake chicken and
biscuit eating Uncle Tom house Negro and
handkerchief head Benedict Arnold and
Judas Iscariot all this from the
tireless opponents of intolerance now
what percentage of her readers think do
you think think that the new york times
from this paragraph called clarence
thomas a chicken and best
eating Uncle Tom I'll bet you like
ninety-nine percent well these aren't
this isn't from the New York Times she
endnotes them and then you have to go
back and back and find oh I see this was
a Playboy interview with somebody or oh
i see this was an SCLC conference she
does this all the time also cheap I'm
kind of an expert on it because in a new
york observer article she called she
said that we were friendly i had met her
once and i guess i made the mistake of
not just saying newer you're horrible I
hate you and
and instead I was cordial so therefore I
showed up as one of her friends so in my
book I have a little thing I say even
people Coulter consider friends says
she's a lying [ __ ] one a horror of a
horror show of epic proportions to oh
the poor thing and a [ __ ] and then the
notes are on the bottom of the page
footnotes one was me and my wife too is
I bid oh the poor thing is my wife to me
and the forces of to another friend I I
don't want to run over my time and but
the book is very wide-ranging it gets
into a lot of things and one of whom end
and I know you don't like name-calling
and I know that you say you were tracked
everything but I do i do have bill on
the cover and I want to just justify
okay can I borrow your water Marley
you're out thanks
thank you taste it first yes because I
really need to tell this right okay and
Bill you know a little bit of this story
a couple years ago i'm watching c-span
which I love to watch and I see Bill
promoting his book no spin zone and he's
on it's a format like this actually it's
a moderator with just with him though
and he says the moderator says something
like you hosted Inside Edition which was
a tabloid show and bill says a tabloid
shall we won to peabodys and I said well
yeah but it was you gotta admit it was
kind of a tabloid showing because um p
buddies only the most prestigious award
in journalism we want to like i said
well yeah but it can't kind of a tabloid
format okay so you want us to give our
2p buddies back so i'm watching this and
I'm going like Inside Edition never won
a Peabody so I Nexus Peabody and Inside
Edition and I do get three hits and
they're all bill saying on his show that
that Inside Edition had 1p buddy here's
one from August 30th i anchored a
program called Inside Edition which is
won a Peabody Award there are 11 may 8th
that got you one too well all I've got
to say is that inside dition as one I
believe you did qualify to Peabody
Awards the highest journalism award in
the country and then on May 19 2000 you
go in this long thing about some says
it's Nevel says he says you hosted
inside ition you say correct which is
that our tabloid show you say by whom by
many people does that mean and even and
then you say we throw the Peabody Awards
back we won Peabody Awards so I go to
the Peabody website and look for inside
ition Peabody Awards and there aren't
any and I call the Peabody people I said
did you guys give it inside edition of
peabody and there was some laughter
and you know cuz I'm thinking what was
it for you know how bear is to bear or
you know something on Madonna's first
you know the father of her first baby
maybe you want it for but they say no
they've never wanted so I call a bill
and you were really nice you called me
back and you said yeah what is it out
and it was very warm and I said I saw
you on c-span you said you want Inside
Edition 12 people is what we did I said
well you really should talk to the
Peabody people about her because they
don't think you did he said I'll call
you back calls me back five minutes
remember this says uh it was a poke I
say a poke he said yeah it's very it's a
just as prestigious as the Peabody I
said so there are two most prestigious
awards and Generals he says al it's very
very prestigious I said well okay don't
you think it's odd that you got it wrong
about a journalism award and he says how
if you want to go after me go ahead so I
say okay so
so I call the Washington Post Oak oi oi
grove at the Washington Post and I
telling the whole thing and he calls
close bill bill says al has a jihad
against me or something so I gotta poke
now now Billings see I had sort of
expected bill to go gee al thanks for
pointing this out boy is that
embarrassing whoo well I don't want to
make that mistake again melrose go ahead
go ahead go after me so bill and the
think knowledge is making a mistake so
big deal you go on your show and say big
deal about few weeks later a colonists
from Newsday picks it up and says right
to the column called not all the facts
on the factor of facts or something like
that and then you do a little special
thing you're out with michael wolf and
on attack journalism it's your it's a
you introduce a personal story segment
on attack journals this is a personal me
because some writers are really
violating every tenant of fairness and
what they're saying and print about your
humble servant and they say i'll give
you an example guy says about me a
couple weeks ago O'Reilly said you want
a Peabody Award never said it this is
why you don't retract things because you
just continues there you can't find a
transcript where I said it you there is
no one on earth you could bring in that
would say I said it Robert Reno Newsday
a columnist writes in his column calls
me a liar all right and it's totally
fabricated that's attack journalism it's
dishonest it's disgusting and it hurts
reputations well wolf media critic from
the New York Magazine says it's also
incorrect journalism if it's wrong it's
wrong okay well then the guy made a
mistake now come on he made a mistake
that's lives forever in nexus and he did
write a calm and did you write a column
the next day saying made a mistake well
obviously obviously you should usually I
find if someone made a mistake if you
ask them to correct that they do correct
it not in this society anymore
so bill I'm sorry I call you one of the
many people who do lie in my book and I
guess we're going to have some question
answer so you have a chance to respond
to that sir so you have a chance to
respond to that and there's others I
mean you know it goes on and on and
there are other so many other people on
the right who do it too and they'll be
enumerated in the book and it's
important and it's really important and
it's important because we've been just
taken it we've been taking it and taking
it on the left you know I went to that
well stone memorial the next day i hear
rush limbaugh on the radio going there
was no memorializing my friends they
distorted that thing i do a case study
of that thing they distorted that
memorial so badly and I got I wish
Tucker were here today because Tucker
the next day said that Republican
senators who'd come who are friends of
Wellstone were shouted down with by
people by the crowd when they're trying
and when they're trying to speak when
they tried to speak that that wasn't the
format of the memorial there was lie
after lie weekly standard Christopher
call well did the most vicious thing on
that on the Wellstone memorial did not
see it all he saw i think were some
clips on fox that mr. Hannon you put
together so i got i got this chapter in
verse and i got it and we're not going
to sit for it anymore we just aren't
okay I'll finish for now I could go on
all day I know you could and I know you
got have just about half yeah bill we
were supposed to be on here for 15
minutes this idiot goes 35 okay all he's
got in six and a half years is that I
misspoke that I labeled a polka water
Peabody he writes it in his book he
tries to make me out shut up you had
your 35 minutes shut up this is what
this guy does bill you what he done you
can't this is what he control Pat come
on I think wait a minute I think I need
a whistle in a striped shirt not to be a
referee maybe I went on long street I
understand can you please put roll him
this guy uses me of being a liar ladies
and gentlemen on national television
because I misspoke and labeled a Peabody
a poke I didn't mention we want war
national headliners okay this is what
this guy does he demonizes it all right
and then other people pick it up now if
it's important to you that I misspoke
and label the Peabody he didn't just
miss fine that's fine okay this is what
he does he's a vicious and that is with
a capital V person who is blinded by
ideology and that's all I'll say about
hungry but thank you very much I think
what we need to do I want to have my
business from all of this the one thing
I want to say to the wonderful book
sellers in this room
if your customers tell you that there
isn't a variety of books coming out this
fall your customers are paying attention
because I must say I think we have shown
here this tremendous range and I think
one of the things that all of us stand
for booksellers and publishers very
vigorously is free speech and freedom of
expression and
I hope we don't take this personal and I
think at this point what we really need
to do is find a way that we're going to
have some questions and see if we can do
this so wish me luck and if anybody does
have a whistle and any of those signals
for filing on or something I'm ready but
at college but it really wants to both
speakers I just want to note that the
Polk is an extremely prestigious
journalism award uh but that my normal
journalistic standards you owe to
correction on that one by the way the
Hulk I'm sorry Molly but the poke that
they won was one a year after bill left
the ship Russian was about the program I
said nothing that I want anything it was
a discussion on the program and why did
you use as I oh na we thank you very
much I appreciate that um okay and I've
also wanted wait a minute I'm not wait a
minute wait a minute wait a minute um
just to say a couple of other things in
our ongoing efforts to achieve civil
discourse one of the things that I
noticed is that we do tend and I know
bill specifically says he tries not to
do this but we do tend to want everybody
you know the left the right and then
accuse the left says this or that and
it's interesting to me because I what I
keep saying to people is I ain't the
left ain't populism my name is Molly
Ivins and when I write about the issue
of possibly no weapons of mass
destruction the first thing i noticed i
have no way in hell of knowing whether
or not there any WMDs over there the
other thing that i wanted to respond to
is the idea that bill specifically said
he wants there to be WMDs because it's
important for the country it would be a
terrible loss of credibility if we don't
find them about what she's absolutely
correct and there's a point i want to
make about that because there's an
implication that people who opposed this
war did so for any reason other than
that we thought it would be terrible for
the country what I did before the war is
predict a short
he wore and the piece from hell and so
far I think I'm two for two I didn't
want us to go into Iraq not because I
didn't understand that Saddam Hussein
was miserable son of a [ __ ] I've been
active in human rights work for 35 years
I knew he was a miserable son of a [ __ ]
when the Reagan administration was
sending in weapons and I said from the
beginning that you could make a case for
going in on humanitarian grounds alone
but that's not the case the Bush
administration made and the only reason
I oppose going in after him is because I
was terribly afraid that this country
would get caught in an awful quagmire
over there and the only reason I opposed
it is because I love this country
bill I would be interested in your and
Molly having a discussion about her
concept of Doug Jones because in a way
you're talking about who's looking out
for you so you're talking about a doug
jones to the difference between miss
Ivan's and myself is that I don't
believe the government can help you all
that much in your life all right I don't
believe that all of the big government
programs that are set up to benefit the
folks most of never get to the folks I
was a high school teacher I know that
money goes it doesn't go to the kids and
you want more money fine any going to
the kids it's discipline its structure
its paying the teachers a better wage
it's training the teachers better all of
those things so I see the world as a
world that self-reliance matters that's
what should be taught all right that's
where I'm coming from you know we talk
about the tax and the deficit well you
know the left now is screaming the
deficit the deficit the deficit I'm
looking at them going look you guys were
driving the big government programs
everything is a Great Society of 1964 I
mean those were massive spending
programs many of which failed dismally
and the corruption it's here in
California for example in a medical
program is astronomical it's a giant
waste safety net yes nanny state no all
right and I don't believe in income
redistribution all right I don't believe
in taking money from me all right who
started out I wait a minute started out
with nothing all right and then giving
somebody else and not regulating out
what that person does with it I just
don't believe that now I respect other
people who believe opposite for me and I
listen to them and evaluate their
argument but from my life sigh I don't
see that as being effective I believe in
drug testing for welfare I believe in
personal responsibility across the board
so that's where I'm coming from in the
in the dub Jones argument all right I'm
coming from this society needs to be
trained in self-reliance and
responsibility ok I think that's a
perfectly legitimate point of view
and listen to it with great respect
again we have this problem though that
my name is Molly Ivins I never went
around saying big government programs
were wonderful um I don't know who you
think I am but I'm not you know liberals
my name is molly ivins it says in the
preamble of the Constitution that there
are six purposes and functions of
government one is to improve the general
welfare I myself have always thought
that meant hit mostly health and
education and it seems to me we are
still in this country not in doing a
very good job on either one and in fact
there is considerable evidence that the
entire health care system is not just
showing cracks it is literally falling
apart I mean the bricks are coming out
of it and what you will see after this
round of state budget cuts I have just
finished covering the legislative
session in Texas which of course
involved being embedded with the troops
in Ardmore Oklahoma they got nine
billion dollars out of a budget that was
never generous believe me Texas state
government is not some wasteful
operation and they cut it all out of
programs that help poor people now I'm
fine with a you know open competition
but I'm a great believer in the equal
starting line I don't want equal results
I don't want everybody to end up in the
same place in life those who work harder
and more talented you all go on and sore
but I want an equal starting line you're
never going to have an equal starting
line you can watch me get it and I write
about this in who's looking out for you
it's the first chapter you will never
have it because some kids have good
parents and some kids have drug-addicted
parents and alcoholic parents because
some kids are born with more gifts and
some left less kiss you will never have
it it's impossible for them why not keep
working at it you can work at it but you
have to work it at it under a very
disciplined structure and I believe that
I believe that the government can
provide that structure but will not
because we live in this age of political
correctness that
just through the roof but one of the
interesting things about the dub Taylor
theory is that the middle class and
working Americans getting squeezed to
death and that's true but why are they
getting squeezed to death three reasons
under President Clinton Americans pay
the highest taxes since world war two
state local and federal all right the
tax burden on someone like me all right
and migrant went over fifty percent in
New York State and in California as well
but the people who were making between
50 and 80 thousand dollars their tax
burden hovering around forty percent
that's forty cents on the dollar taken
away from them yet real estate prices to
buy a home in this state in Southern
California here or in my state of New
York or Massachusetts or Chicago or
anywhere where people cluster to make it
have gone right crazy so that the
mortgage takes way more money than it
took from my parents and then the
educational costs if you send your kids
to college the three combined just make
the average American in debt so I'm
saying the more money that you have to
control in your life the better it is
and that the government had one of the
bush makes his mistake in the sense that
he wants to cut taxes but he won't
impose discipline on the Pentagon for
example where one trillion dollars has
been misappropriated not stolen they
don't know where it is there's a guy
named David Walker's ahead of the GAO
he's a really good guy he's one of the
best public servants in the United
States of America they call Walker in
and miss Schroeder noses because she was
on these committees and the Pentagon
cannot account right now for a trillion
dollars a trillion dollars they don't
know where it is that's the fallacy the
Bush administration they won't impose
the discipline so when the money is
allotted to the education or the
Pentagon or whatever it is that it's run
like a private company that you have to
go back to the stockholders and say
here's where the money went okay wait a
minute I really have to jump in here the
idea that private corporations are more
efficient than government is absolute
crap
now we've now we part ways now we part
ways there is something that economists
are now studying which is as a result of
enron worldcom etc it's called control
fraud when the fish rots from the head
down which is what happened at Enron the
whole chapter in our book about that the
idea that a government in the private
why do you think the Pentagon is so
screwed up it's all private defense
contractors within this cost overruns
it's the seven hundred dollar handwrite
is nobody opposes your silence said
don't do that you can't do that as
you're absolutely right on private
contractors are not you know in the
defense industry it's in the poverty
industry it's in the educational
industry it's across the board am I
being punished no no no I'm sorry I
wanted I wanted also to respond on that
on me I just thought we'd have a Doug
Jones argument over okay no no I'm
enjoying the debate I don't going to be
but I could actually participate in it I
I wanted also to respond on the economic
argument I don't believe in an income
redistribution to this extent if look at
look at this current tax situation fifty
percent of the people in this country
and now paying more in payroll taxes
than they are an income tax of 80
pursuant thank you when the bush
administration discusses tax
distribution all they talk about his
income tax they could I only miss
represent the actual tax burden on
people in this country the WIC quota guy
named be Rapoport who is rather an
unusual Texas millionaire and what he
says if you're making fifty thousand
dollars a year you're paying eight
thousand dollars in income tax is that
it will put you in the poor house but it
was sure as hell Crump your foot cramp
your budget I make a million dollars a
year I play four hundred thousand
dollars in taxes that leaves me with six
hundred thousand dollars to live on you
could have feel sorry for me you deserve
your money you earned your money all
right now you want to take money from
people who have earned the money alright
and you want to give it to other people
now what do this not point to any
constitutional I don't want a revision
to that says
if you want a socialistic quasi
socialistic say let's have a referendum
I don't move on it I don't make arriving
property away from people and give it to
other people okay okay wait a minute
wait a minute wait a minute wow this is
way over your head all right we'll call
you when we need you go back over there
I'm not unlike Molly I am a liberal and
and the idea that government programs
can't help people is ridiculous and I
I'll give you a story I mean you you
like to say you came from the poorest
background possible you've said that no
I haven't yes you have a working class
leviton company it's another difficult
you grow up in westbury or levittown the
westbury section of Levittown all right
which i've defined 87 times economy and
a bio you know we'll send it by the way
I why don't you come over to my house my
mother lives there come on over we'll
have a bagel all right oh come on oh I
would love that this is a random victim
yeah I'll give me an example um and I
don't think my wife will mine because
I'm writing about it in the book when my
wife should move back to the thing is
this yeah yeah okay I was just trying to
get in here there are a couple things I
can talk about I mean when you say I'm
way this is above me I remember being on
your show and saying that 93 Clinton had
passed his budget deficit reduction act
that one Republican vote and you said
outlets impossible and I said no he did
it without one Republican vote and you
didn't understand I guess at the time
that both houses were Democrat and both
you know so this isn't way over my head
okay we'll give you an honorary PhD L
unbelievable unbelievable anyway any
questions any questions from the folks
out if you get about it or anything did
bill just cut me off
well oh you had you had 45 minutes up
here come on 45 at least seem that way
it always seems longer when none of us
have the microphone I know but it really
wasn't can I finish it but just about my
wife story when my wife was 18 months
old her father died in the car accident
her mother was 27 with five kids one
younger than my wife they made it
scraped by my mother-in-law didn't have
an education she worked in a grocery
store in the produce department she made
it barely scraped by because of Social
Security from her from her husband they
got the house on the GI loan they turned
the phone off a lot they turn the heat
off a lot they lived in portland maine
but the government saved their ass and
this is you know what this is actually
serious the stuff and the fact is when
Clinton you know you may remember that
in the 90s during Clinton he raised the
top level and it didn't stop people who
were in the top 1% from working or
producing jobs he created 23 million
jobs and every Republican said that was
going to cause a recession and you
remember it didn't actually pass with
any Republican votes not one okay
alright so baby
let me say about all of this this has
been the last week was a very good week
for me because it's the author of the
Family Medical Leave the supreme court
upheld at six to three with Rehnquist on
my side I never thought that would
happen so one of my great hopes for the
planet is if we all keep talking
together maybe we'll figure this all out
and I think it is very difficult it's a
very difficult time I think for
everybody to try and figure out what's
going on but I think it's only fair
hearts that sorry open it up to the
audience because they may have some
viewpoints out here do we have anybody
who is not shy there's someone over here
in a gray suit yeah the question is the
redistricting fight that drove the Texas
legislatures to seek refuge in Oklahoma
a great moment in the history of our
state um I've been covering the
legislature for a long time and I've
seen some strange maps before I've seen
districts that look like dying chickens
and districts that look like oil snakes
remember one time during a redistricting
fight on old boy named guy Floyd stood
up and said to the chairman delwyn Jones
they'll win look I hear what she had
done to my district got a great big old
ball on one end and runs in a little
bitty old strip for 300 miles he's got a
great big old ball on the other end now
the courts say the districts have to be
compact in contiguous is this your idea
compact and contiguous no one thought
about it for a moment and said well you
know artistic sense it is
and the map produced by tom delay and
that's exactly who produced it was
artistic to the max it was sort of in
the Salvador Dali of art really a
stunning piece of work and I really do
think that there I know it sounds picky
and petty because the whole thing it's
ludicrous nothing in Texas ever happens
I mean serious stuff happens with very
serious implications but it always
happens with this weird hitch in the get
along and you just have to accept that
Texans are always going to you know be
producing ridiculous goddamn stuff I
mean it just always happens down there
and Richard says you know the price of
gas in Texas has got so high women who
want to run over their husbands have to
carpool now oh but there is a very
serious point not only do the
Republicans have no right to come back
and we and RAM a new redistricting map
down anybody's throat at this point I
mean listen once a decade for this
horror is enough and the second point is
that during the search for the missing
legislatures a truly epic effort delay
called the FAA and the Justice
Department about trying to track them
down and apparently our state police got
the Department of Homeland Security
which is supposed to be tracking down
terrorists to try and find one of the
plane that was involved well you know
using government resources for partisan
political purposes is is really serious
stuff I mean I realize it's a petty and
absurd escapade but that's really pretty
serious stuff now i just also wanted to
say that as far as we know redistricting
is now dead they may unless they're
forced into a special session and at
which point i think governor good here
would put it back on
and let me say I call him good here
because Governor Perry has a head of
hair that every Texan can be proud of
regardless of party very good anybody
else have a question there's one over
here this gentleman yeah this uh
question for Al Franken I heard while
back you're working with an shell media
to try to get a liberal talk show format
to counterbalance the controlling
conservative talk show right format in
the corporately owned stations which is
even more important now because of the
news with the corporation's buying out
multiple radio stations can you give us
an update on those efforts yeah we're
trying to get a liberal or progressive
radio network together and it's I want
to do it and if we can get and I want to
if I fail I want to fail big so we want
to try to get enough funding together to
have a huge failure now I think there's
an audience out there and I i I'm dying
to do it and the more I researched this
book and the more I look at and and I'm
sorry but I made this seem like the book
is not there's only one little chapter
on bill but but they're much more than
the one you'll really be interested in
the book don't but there's there's Bush
stuff I mean there there's just you know
just stuff to every day not every day
but Bush will show up at a Children's
Hospital say that this is so important
what we're doing and then the next day
cut funding and he doesn't over and over
and over again and there were so many
lies in the two thousand campaign member
this was the gutted military this was
the hollowed out military the military
when Bush in his acceptance speech said
if they're asked to report two units of
the of the army would have to say to
whole divisions would have said not
ready for duty sir and of course they
were and the joint chairman of the Joint
Chiefs said they were
not only that but richard armitage in
testimony in the Armed Services
Committee a few days later said well
yeah they are and I went up at the White
House Correspondents Dinner to a Paul
Wolfowitz I said didn't the Clinton
military do a great job in Iraq and he
said after you and then we had a little
argument I think he was kidding on the
square on the fu i thought he's being
funny and I appreciated that but a
Cheney said in 91 after the Gulf War
that any president fights with the
military given to him by his predecessor
come on and he said the first call he
made after the Gulf War was done was to
President Reagan to thank him so the
Bastile that people lie in campaigns is
at the point I'm shocked know is that
they longer in office and they continue
to lie and that also that it doesn't
getting out it doesn't it isn't fair and
balanced and what we want to do what I
want to do is be able I you know what
i'll tell you what i'll talk about firm
balance when you edit this together i
know you're going to show this for the
to the factor audience can I be in the
Edit room with you to help you know kind
of because but I would you know look I
love I would love to c span audience
we're doing a propaganda show I put you
in the editing room you're a genius at
that you're you're the best
propagandists I've ever seen but if you
now Sean Hannity people who agree with
you in this room even people who agree
with you in this room okay will they
can't possibly think that your objective
that you're looking at life to be fair
to come to a fair conclusion sure the
bush in cheney people told lies what
clinton gore didn't tell any lies did
you miss the gym Larry interview how
come on yeah I think that you may can I
agreed I make a nice living being a
propagandist and more power to you but
so much yourself up as a truth teller
because you're not well here's the thing
is in the bush
I am in the I am though I that's the
that's the difference between you and me
in the rush limbaugh is a big fat idiot
I and other observations I wrote a book
on Russian it was a way to get at the
Gingrich right and not one fact was
challenged in that book there was one
when I read the book yeah he's gonna
challenge I to read the book rush rush
limbaugh's a big fatty it was number one
bucks to see that come on you're
preaching to the choir that's no no no
no no no no no even John fund the guy
who ghostwrote Russia's first book came
to me and said you did a really good job
there was one fat one thing as I quoted
a Kathleen Hall Jamison study in my
thing which was in his preliminary phase
and the findings of that changed after
thinking through but i'm telling you i
have this thing is thoroughly researched
and i do tell the truth and when I and
and if I do get caught or if i do say
something wrong I admit it and the the
whole point of what i said here was that
when you were caught you look at all you
got we heard it Alice all you got after
six and a half years I told you it isn't
your client attic if this is all you got
after six and Anna told you it isn't you
are pathetic it is it yeah I got a lot
more and if it's his lame is that it's
unbelievable I have a wonderful idea i'm
going to ask the futures of all three of
these authors have a partisan
complimentary books to each author and I
love lad Leary miss Ivan's book
blathering oh I will have a little
reading lesson here and see where we all
come out at the end um do we have time
for one more not one more she says okay
well I think it'll help sales if you
talk about my book on your show
okay you get the last question you
reckon so well I want to thank all the
speakers for a lively lunch you know it
strikes me that this dialogue is good
entertainment but at another level it
actually is of some concern to me for
our Republic and that is the difficulty
of trying to get people to come together
and have an effective discourse that
really as a result of the discourse
brings people together more than spreads
them apart and and I would really like
to hear a brief comment from each of you
of what you think might be something
constructive that you might do to help a
discourse that could bring the differing
views in this country together versus
split them further apart I'll take that
first I work with political humor a lot
because I find that if you can get
people to start by laughing about
something it sort of clears out the
cobwebs in their mind and they focus on
whatever you have to say without the
distraction and whatever it was they
were thinking of before which according
to studies of college students is sex in
ninety five percent of the cases I have
worried about the poisoning of the well
of public discourse considerably myself
and to the extent that i'm known as a
mean writer i just want to point out
that i only take shots at politicians i
realize they have wives and mothers but
no one ever held a gun to their heads
and force them to run for public office
and as far as I'm concerned they are all
in a free-fire zone no civilians and I
never bother with the
meanness of political discussion today
there are lots of villains I mean it's
not just Rush Limbaugh and it's not just
you know whoever you want a name there
is a nastiness about it and I was really
appalled to see Grover Norquist who's a
extremely well-known figure on the on
the right in the what they call the
movement people who call themselves
movement conservatives and he said that
their goal was to bring Washington level
by 2 / a shin and partisanship to state
houses around the country they're saying
is that bipartisanship is like being
seduced either they have an ugly way of
saying it and to find somebody actually
saying you know we want more anger we
want more you know we hatred expressed
and when you talk to people who get so
angry about politics that their faces
turn red and their veins stand out on
their necks and they shake their waddles
like a turkey gobbler so angry about it
you know you just want to go most real
politicians are far less passionate than
that whenever you have money in power
you can have strife and through the
years of our republic we've always had
very very contentious debate in a
political realm because power is a
seducer it's something that people will
sell their souls for so is money so is
sex so that people like me and Miss
ivans who are new basically news
analysts we analyze what happens and
from my point of view what I try to do
is look out for you in a sense I try to
look this is the issue here's what I
think about it here's how I've arrived
at my conclusion when I said in the
beginning I'm trying to convince you to
think like me but I'm trying to give you
a perspective that's clear I can't bring
people together it's not my job all
right it's not what I do my job is
unfortunately to rattle cages to put the
bad guys on alert
here we come all right and you better
shape up you better stop doing or start
doing better all right so there's no way
on earth that I can advance the cause of
people coming together but you need
people like me you need watch dogs and
one of the reasons the o'reilly factor
has been successful in publishing on
radio and on television is because we
are not timid for years the network news
the standardized Network News and CNN
were too afraid to do what we do too
afraid there were no commentators on
there they were aligned to Sunday
morning they wouldn't go after the
sacred cows both in a Republicans and
the Democrats they wouldn't even give
voices to pro-life people unless they
blew up an abortion clinic all right so
it was a stranglehold that's broken down
it's broken down all across the board
there are as many left voices as rice
voices in the media you can get NPR you
can get Rush Limbaugh you can get what
you want to get but at my level and I
think miss live-ins is in print pretty
much does what I do we have to make
judgments and these judgments are harsh
and these judgments have to be sold in a
way that arouses people's ire or things
will never get better so that's what I
am I'm a watchdog a populist watchdog
I'm looking out trying to make
everybody's life better and give you
ammunition where you can fight the
charlatans you can fight the people who
are hurting you oh um I consider myself
a nice guy and I don't like vituperation
but I feel sometimes sometimes you have
to stand up and fight and I feel like
there is a I think one of the reasons
that Fox beats CNN for example is that
CNN tries to play things down the middle
and there's a certain dullness to it and
there's a certain you know I mean Roger
Ailes invented the Housh that was a big
contribution to cable and but I I think
that our voices are not heard and I just
I just want and by the way there were
you know there were pro-life voices on
TV before I remember ralph reed east
again on TV everyone's well i just
believe that it is it is time that those
of us who are liberal i'm i'm a dlc
democrat but I and you know I Paul
Wellstone with some I loved but he
wasn't you know I disagree with him a
lot and I like bringing people together
and I have a lot of Republican friends I
i do know really honest and but i just
think that I don't I don't I think what
I do does civilized the discourse
because I think you just have to call
people on it and and call people on
there in civility and if you know if
they know there are watch dogs out there
who are saying you can't say that you
can't get away with that al excuse me
but I just the title of your book is
liar liar big liar and you're advancing
the cause of civility is that what I'm
getting here well first of all that's
not the title of my book but you came
close unbelievable ladies and gentlemen
and I'm glad you're all here to see it
well I I get any way you know the thing
is Bill if you want if you you kept
saying the thing about that's all you
got after six years and then you
complained about how long I went on if
you want me to go on for several hours I
can go into some other stuff but the
point is that I was trying to make is
that there are people on the right
especially who are so vituperative who
are who are Grover Norquist who said
basically bipartisan what molly ivins is
about to say is that he said by part
bipartisanship is date rape that's what
he said and I i think that there's a
place for a voice there there are voices
Molly's one of them Molly's a great one
but there are there
is a place to call people on on things
and that's that's what I do and I think
that does increase ability and the name
of the book is not what you said it's
lies and the lying liars who tell them a
fair and balanced look at the right and
with that ladies and gentlemen I think
it is time that we thank our authors
thank our audience and life goes on
where are we